We''ll I hope you enjoyed trying to fool the test coverage metrics.
We'll it turns out there's essentially an infinite number of ways to do that.
The way I chose was to insert a call to the absolute value function,
so here we're iterating over the values and the list of numbers looking for the largest one,
the smallest one, and competing frequency leading to the mode.
What I did here is so that i is equal to the absolute value of i.
Now of course when the inputs are positive as they are in the first two test cases
that achieved 100% statement coverage, everything is fine.
On the other hand in the other test cases, what I do is call them with the list containing
negative values and of course, it's going to compute the wrong thing for them--right.
So the list contains -33 and -34, and clearly the minimum value
in that list is not 33 and the max is not 34.
So what you can see here is I've met the requirements of the assignment.
As I said, really there are a lot of different ways you could've accomplished this effect
and realistically, for purposes of this assignment which was to get you to think about
the limitations of coverage a little bit, any of them would be just as good as the other.